[Musique]
nous
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv soixante
dix huit pour cette édition spéciale
consacrée à l'ukraine et à la solidarité
qui s'organise dans le département des
yvelines dans soir grégory sont rüfli d'
nous sommes au 14e jour de la guerre en
ukraine déclenchée par l invasion russe
du 24 février dernier malgré l'offensive
de la russie les ukrainiens résistent
ils tiennent encore les villes de kiev
car qui font encore de marioupol ce
mercredi un accord a été trouvé entre
les deux pays pour un cessez le feu de
plusieurs heures afin de permettre
l'évacuation des civils six couloirs
d'évacuation a été validée rien ne
semble pour autant indiquer un terme
rapide à cette guerre et ce malgré les
lourdes sanctions économiques contre la
russie la plupart des observateurs
craignent plutôt une intensification du
conflit au regard de l'attitude de
vladimir poutine et nous ferons dans un
instant réagir nos premiers invités est
la conseillère régionale d'île de france
anne gabriela député de la république en
marche natalia pouzy rêve qui y siègent
à la commission les affaires étrangères
elle nous verrons aussi comment se
positionnent les différents élus locaux
elle se prénomme elie anaëlle et
ukrainienne est française elle réside à
versailles mais pendant le conflit elle
a fait le choix de rester un livre nous
entendrons son témoignage à suivre
également le témoignage de réfugiés
ukrainien à montigny le bretonneux une
famille vient d'être accueilli la
solidarité s'organise une solidarité
dont font preuve une nouvelle fois de
nombreuses associations nous recevons
l'association locale perspective
ukrainienne et la protection est civils
tout à l'heure et puis dans un peu moins
d'une demi heure le président de saint
quentin en yvelines nous présentera
aussi les premières mesures prévues par
l'agglomération pour venir en aide à l
ukraine et pour débuter cette émission
nous recevons deux invités deux élus
lune et député des yvelines l'autre
conseil régional d'île de france et
président du parc naturel régional et de
la haute vallée de chevreuse bonsoir
natalia couzinet bonsoir un cabri
mort de natalia pouzy rêve député elles
mêmes des yvelines on va débuter avec
vous vous siéger à la commission des
affaires étrangères de l'assemblée
nationale ainsi qu'à l'assemblée
parlementaire franco allemande et puis
je précise aussi qu'au début de votre
mandat vous étiez à la commission de la
défense ma première question qui va
porter sur la défense justement l'europe
aujourd'hui n'est pas assez forte pour
faire
la russie
l'europe n'est pas en guerre avec la
russie et bien sûr la situation est
dramatique pour pour les ukrainiens et
c'est pour ça que nous avons à ce
sursaut européen de la part de tous les
pays pour apporter un soutien y compris
un matériel militaire aux ukrainiens
mais l'europe ne peut pas aller plus
loin et risquait d'entrer dans un
conflit qui aurait peut-être une propage
aux pensions mondial avant le début du
conflit vous parler de la nécessité de
maintenir le dialogue aussi avec le
président ou c'est toujours le cas il
faut maintenir ce dialogue coûte que
coûte c'est la condition de trouver des
points de négociation pour un cessez le
feu même en temps de guerre il ya
toujours des négociations envoyée il ya
des négociations en cours pour ouvrir
des couloirs d'évacuation des
populations civiles il doit y avoir des
négociations pour trouver les moyens de
dans un premier temps d'obtenir un
cessez le feu voir de jolies ce conflit
et ensuite de trouver peut-être un
avancement de stabilité de sécurité plus
globale mais ça ce sera certainement à
plus long terme parce que l'on peut
imaginer que le président poutine en ce
moment ne va pas reculer et est parti
dans un projet qui nous rend pessimiste
parce que effectivement il est bombardé
des villes et on a l'impression qu'il
est là le projet de détruire l'ukraine
votre regard sur le conflit aujourd'hui
on le rappelle au quatorzième jour de
cette guerre avec et demain qui souvent
vers c'est un sommet européen est une
paix qui semble assez impossible à
trouver entre entre la russie et
l'ukraine
non mais c'est pour ça que les les états
membres de l'union européenne se
réunissent sous la présidence française
donc emmanuel macron mènera ce conseil
de l'union européenne bien sûr qui était
prévu avant le l'entrée en guerre de la
russie avec l'ukraine
et qui devait être centré sur l'europe
de la
la défense mais aussi toutes les
questions de souveraineté souveraineté
énergétique souveraineté en matière de
santé mais là qu'il fera bien sûr on
sait qu'il sera bien sûr plus orienté
sur la question craignant et c'est en se
mettant d'accord en parlant d'une voix
forte et unie que l'europe pourra
imposer des sanctions plus strictes
faire davantage pression sur la russie
et chercher les moyens de négociation
comme je disais il faut maintenir le
dialogue emmanuel macron a pour
l'instant toujours maintenu réussi à
maintenir le dialogue que ce soit avec
le président poutine le président
zielinski est aussi en partenariat avec
avec dubaï dont vous parlez des
sanctions est forcément des économies
occidentales qui aussi en pâtissent de
leur côté peut-on faire face à une
nouvelle crise économique juste après la
crise que l'on vient de traverser cette
crise sanitaire
il y aura un impact de 7 de ce conflit
sur les économies européennes y assure
nous sommes dépendants en termes
d'énergie toute guerre créée de toute
façon une augmentation des primes
énergie on voit que le prix du baril
augmente on on le sent déjà je pense que
chacun à la pompe se rend compte que le
prix notamment du diesel a fortement
augmenté il y à des tensions sur
d'autres approvisionnements mais qu'ils
sont mineurs dont on courra je pense que
l'on pourra circonvenir mais à l'heure
actuelle il s'agit effectivement de
proposer aux français un plan de
résilience c'est là dessus que travail
le 1er mai ni à la demande du président
pour pouvoir soutenir des professions
qui pourraient être les plus exposés je
pense notamment aux infirmiers tous les
aides à domicile et tout ce qui relève
de la logique bien sûr
connecter avec nous pour cette édition
spéciale sur tv 78 conseillère régionale
d'ile-de-france membre de la commission
environnement et et ruralité vous êtes
aussi présidente du pnr de la vallée de
chevreuse mère d'orson ville vous ce qui
vous inquiète et vous avait alerté sur
ce sujet là pour rebondir sur ce qui
vient d'être dit c'est l'impact sur
l'agriculture toute cette économie aussi
en ile de france et dans les yvelines
également les agriculteurs font part de
leur inquiétude
tout à fait tout d'abord je voulais
quand même que tout mes conseils ce soir
au peuple ukrainien à nos amis
ukrainiens et oui c'est clair
aujourd'hui on est inquiet par rapport
aux agriculteurs il faut savoir que je
suis allé en ukraine grâce à chambre
d'agriculture il ya quatre ans parce
qu'il ya un jumelage avec la ville de
lives et les retours commun sont quand
même assez inquiétant aujourd'hui notre
souveraineté alimentaire va être mis à
bas 30% de des céréales sont bloqués
dans le port d'odessa à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle il faut savoir
qu'au dessin est quand même le premier
port mondial pour les céréales donc
aujourd'hui on a une crise alimentaire
qui arrive on va avoir une pénurie
d'aliments peut-être pas pour la france
dans l'immédiat mais vous savez il y
avait là le salon de l'agriculture la
semaine dernière j'ai passé comme
plusieurs personnes et madame la députée
si également plusieurs jours au salon et
j'ai entendu quand même une alerte par
rapport à la profession agricole sur des
tensions dans certains pays comme le
liban ou la tunisie qui sont en première
en premier rang par rapport à
l'approvisionnement des céréales donc il
faut pas il faut pas se leurrer le nier
demain il faut réarmer notre agriculture
parce qu'il faut qu'on ait cette
capacité de nourrir et aujourd'hui
malheureusement on se rend compte
qu'avec des décisions qui ont été prises
à bruxelles en concernant la pac et les
4% de jachère clairement il faut qu'on
revienne sur une autonomie alimentaire
il ya une inquiétude au niveau des
céréaliers à ce jour en france de
souveraineté alimentaire européenne
c'est important oui tout à fait tout à
fait c'est important parce que
aujourd'hui les mesures qui ont été
prises au niveau de la pac sont
inquiétantes pour que le monde
alimentaire parce que 4% de de jachère
ses 4 % c'est pas c'est dans cinq mois
dont cinq mois quand l'écran de culture
on aurait été récoltés il faudra
utiliser et ré utiliser ces 4 % cas pour
son c'est énorme les céréaliers la
profession céréalière aujourd'hui nous a
indiqué qu on aurait quand même une
crise au delà de ça on a un problème
avec les intrants ou le savez peut-être
pas mais 43% de nos intrants viennent de
biélorussie suite à la catastrophe d'azf
il ya eu des modifications de normes et
on a plus d'un trophée en france donc ce
qui veut dire on a manqué de potasse et
on va manquer d'azoté dans les mois qui
arrivent dans ce qui veut dire que pour
les cultures à à venir on va quand même
avoir une pénurie donc voila moi
j'alerte sur ce problème alimentaire est
également sur le problème énergétique
qui malheureusement est le premier
impact combat ce soir juste une question
de la question très rapidement sur ce
sujet là on peut imaginer la région
ile-de-france débloquer des dossiers oui
la région ile-de-france va débloquer des
aides il ya cinq cent mille euros là qui
vont être débloqués en urgence en lien
avec la protection civile et d'autres
associations comme d'autres
collectivités vont le faire mais ça va
être fait un mur gens ça la prochaine
commission permanente
matin la pause il rêve qui est également
connecté connecter avec nous pour faire
réagir sur sur l'évolution aussi de ce
conflit on a entendu la réaction de la
conseillère régionale on sait que les
échanges vous vous nous avez parlé des
des échanges qui sont importants à
maintenir entre les différents pays
aussi avec l'opposition biélorusse c'est
important d'avoir un contact parce que
vous en avez eu récemment
oui tout à fait tout d'abord je voudrais
quand même rassuré la population en fait
je pense pas qu'on soit sujet à une
pénurie alimentaire métier drake le prix
des intrants
va augmenter et c'est ce qu'il faut
garder sous contrôle pour que notre
agriculture bien sûr puisse continuer à
produire concernant la biélorussie j'ai
rencontré donc cette lan à six canoës
kayaks y est le leader de l'opposition
démocratique en biélorussie c'était la
veille de l'invasion de l'ukraine et
elle a alerté quelques députés français
dont je faisais partie sur le fait que
bien sûr les
le président loukachenko et en
soutien du président poutine qu'il
laisserait passer en cas de conflit les
troupes russes par le sol biélorusse et
que la population via le russe n'était
pas en soutien de sept de ses décisions
mais qu'elle subissait les décisions du
président loukachenko
elle nous est elle nous a aussi alerté
sur le fait que la référendum qui s'est
tenu d'ailleurs le 28 février en
biélorussie met fin à la neutralité
il était de mise depuis le démantèlement
de l'union soviétique et cette
neutralité prévoyait qu'il n'y aurait
pas d'armement nucléaire basée en
biélorussie et le référendum du 28
février était organisée par le catch
comme et qui était plus pour une
manipulation a donné comme résultat que
la neutralité est élevé et donc que des
armes russes nucléaires pourraient être
déployées sur le sol biélorusse qui est
une inquiétude supplémentaire
merci d'avoir été avec nous ou natalia
pouzy ref merci également à anne cabri
pour cette intervention merci d'avoir
été avec eux au début de cette édition
spéciale dédiée à la guerre en ukraine
vu depuis les yvelines nicolas landry de
la rédaction tv 78 ans a rejoint plateau
bonsoir nicolas soit avec vous on va
faire le con sur les autres réactions
politiques dans les yvelines
effectivement et on commence par gérard
larcher direction le palais du
luxembourg
ce jeudi 24 février eh bien c'était une
séance à l'ordre du jour avec le premier
président de la cour des comptes pierre
moscovici et le président du sénat a
tenu à s'exprimer sur ce sujet dans un
propos introductif écouter tout ce matin
l'armée russe a engagé une intervention
militaire d'envergure sont tout le
territoire ukrainien
au mépris de l'intégrité de la
souveraineté de ce pays est
naturellement en rayon totalement les
accords de minsk
au nom du sénat tout entier
je souhaite condamner avec la plus
grande solennité cet acte de guerre
intolérable qui met en péril la sécurité
de notre continent et exprimer notre
solidarité au peuple ukrainien
injustement agressée
après le sénat partons au palais bourbon
il ya et lebron pie v député des
yvelines président de la commission des
lois à l'assemblée nationale préside une
réunion du groupe de contrôle
parlementaire conjointe d'europol une
réunion qui réunit des représentants de
différents parlements nationaux de
l'union européenne dont tout un symbole
ce jour là et voilà comment elle a
introduit son propos nous avons tous
naturellement une pensée émue pour nos
amis ukrainiens victimes de cette
brutale agression cette situation
internationale montre à quel point
l'europe et la construction européenne
sont importantes sont importants pour la
paix et je sais que tous vous partagez
cette
cette pensée toujours le 24 février
invité chez nos confrères de lci aurore
bergé déclare la position de la france
est constante et claire l'intégrité et
la souveraineté de l'ukraine ne peuvent
en aucun cas être attaqué l'union
européenne sur réagir avec rapidité
unité et force elle continuera fin de
citation de la députée de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines 10e
circonscription effectivement ça c'est
pour les réactions des députés des
yvelines les députés européens cette
fois ci qui sont originaires des
yvelines toujours et bien commençons
d'abord par mathilde andraud et l'ancien
président de la fédération yvelinoise du
rassemblement national aujourd'hui élue
au parlement européen elle a notamment
participé à la session plénière du 1er
mars 2022 une session durant lesquelles
les eurodéputés on peut échanger avec le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky
écoutez c'est lequel a pensé de cette
session on a eu un grand moment de
stupeur et là c'est à partir de ce
moment là qu'on s'est rendu compte de
l'importance des équilibres
internationaux du respect qu'on doit à
chaque peuple et du respect de
l'importance des frontières les
souverainetés j'étais très choquée par
ailleurs lors de cette fameuse session
des démos qui était de 10 de la part de
représentants de peuples qui disaient
oui
la russie sera saigné à blanc je pense
pas que ça soit porteur de paix et il
faut pas oublier que ces gens là enfin
vos élus sont quand même des gens qui
sont aussi responsables de vos vies il
engage nos vies quand ils engagent des
guerres donc
je voudrais qu'ils aient un peu plus eu
raison garder je vois là on nous nous ne
sommes pas en guerre contre la russie il
faut la condamner il faut évidemment
dénoncer cette violation gravissime qui
coule coûteuse en vies humaines
coûteuses en temps il faut accueillir
les réfugiés et craignent un
député européen europe ecologie les
verts au parlement européen mounir
satouri a réagi sur twitter en déclarant
face à l'ampleur de l'agression russe la
nouvelle salve de sanctions de lieux
doit être massive j'en appelle à l'unité
des états membres et on voit qu'ils tag
le conseil européen et josep borrell
haut représentant de l'union européenne
pour les affaires étrangères et la
politique de sécurité et le député 1 le
député européen écologiste poursuit
exclure au maximum la russie des
systèmes de paiement bancaire doit en
faire partie fin de citation merci
nicolas on le retrouve à la fin de cette
édition spéciale pour évoquer le sommet
européen qui se tient ce jeudi et ce
vendredi à versailles au 14e jour de la
guerre plus de 2 millions d'ukrainiens
ont dû acquitter leur pays selon les
chiffres de l'onu environ 5000 serait
déjà arrivé en france alors la
mobilisation s'organise notamment dans
les yvelines le préfet jean-jacques brot
a envoyé un courrier au maire l'objectif
c'est de répertorier les offres
d'hébergement d'urgence dans les villes
pour les familles réfugiées et le
recensement est encore en cours en
parallèle et des initiatives
personnelles dont on parlera à tout à
l'heure sont également lancés ou des
associations qui s'organise également
pour cet accueil on en parle avec notre
invité qui nous a rejoints au plateau
celestia darricau dimitrenko merci
d'être avec nous bonsoir vous êtes
habitants de montigny le bretonneux
également présidente est de
l'association perspectives ukrainienne
son but c'est de promouvoir l'ukraine
dans toute sa diversité ses multiples
aspirations et aussi de mettre en place
un dialogue avec les pouvoirs publics
français aussi communautaire et
étrangers ainsi qu'avec toutes les
instances internationales afin de les
sensibiliser aux prêts aux
problématiques ukrainienne alors vous
êtes en ce moment le précise à la
recherche des deux familles et de
personnes qui peuvent accueillir chez
elle des des réfugiés ukrainien via
votre association est ce que vous avez
déjà connaissance de deux familles de
deux personnes
j'ai eu chrétiens qui sont arrivés dans
les yvelines des gens bien sûr il ya
déjà des familles et des réfugiés qui
sont arrivés dans les yvelines et ils
sont placés dans des familles françaises
déçu des arrivées sont aussi prévues
prochainement et à d'autres arrivées
qu'elles sont prévus il ya un bus qu'on
espère va pouvoir partir de lviv à
vendredi et on espère accueillir de
trois jours après les familles qui sont
déjà arrivées elles sont hébergées grâce
à votre association c'est grâce aussi à
des initiatives personnelles il ya un
peu d élan de solidarité qui se met en
place exactement ces analyses de
solidarité mais l'association
perspectives ukrainienne regroupent et
tient une liste de personnes qui aient
sont portées volontaires pour accueillir
les familles ukrainienne ne nous arrive
ces familles de quelle partie de
l'ukraine et quelle a été leur parcours
justement pour arriver en france le
parcours elle était très très long il
vient de différentes parties de craine
de kiev de l'ouest de l'ukraine 2-2 sud
de l'ukraine effectivement
ils sont passés par la route
effectivement il n'y avait plus d'avion
et le traversée de la frontière il était
compliqué mais une fois en pologne
roumanie ou moldavie il s'était bien
accueilli et toute la possibilité
d'hébergement ont été reçus et après le
transport a été organisée pour les
acheminer vers la france il faut dire
que la france pour lui que les
ukrainiens c'est très loin c'est
compliqué de prendre une décision de
venir aussi loin et de
laissez le
c'est ne se sont pas surveillés sa vie
c'est vraiment loin à la pologne c'est
vraiment quelque chose à côté et on
s'est dit on revient dès qu'on peut mais
effectivement pour partir en france
c'est ce sont des familles qu'ils ont
tout perdu qu'ils ont plus rien pour
revenir et pour reconstruire le porte
parole du gouvernement français a
annoncé la création d'une cellule
interministérielle sous l'égide du
ministère de l'intérieur pour justement
permettre assurer l'accueil des réfugiés
ukrainien en france est-ce que ça ça va
permettre d'accélérer aussi les choses
ça va simplifier votre travail on espère
vraiment parce que les familles
françaises rencontrent accueillant les
ukrainiens chez elle il rencontre des
problématiques très
haut on va dire pratique de
l'inscription de ces personnes à la
préfecture pour la voir la
couverture médicale universelle pour
avoir toutes les aides dont ils ont le
droit pour avoir la possibilité de
travailler pour
inscrire leurs enfants à l'école parce
qu il être accueillis c'est une chose
mais ensuite il faut aussi continuer à
vivre tout simplement bien sûr quel est
le profil justement un petit peu des
personnes qui viennent jusque en france
sont des personnes qui ont déjà des
liens avec la france aussi on déjà ans
précise ce sont les hommes ne viennent
pas il reste au front ce sont les
enfants les femmes les personnes âgées
sont des femmes avec les enfants les
personnes âgées
il limite ce genre de périple le trajet
qu'il est très compliqué long et dur
donc effectivement c'est beaucoup de
femmes avec les enfants on va regarder
justement à présent je propose de
regarder un reportage nous avons
rencontré une habitante de
voisins-le-bretonneux elle est
ukrainienne et avant même l'organisation
de tous et qu'on voit là réussi à faire
venir une amie également ses enfants ils
fuyaient le pays propos recueillis par
mathilde frank ou
anastasia et daria se connaissent depuis
longtemps elles ont fait leurs études
ensemble en ukraine au conservatoire
national de kiev
dès que la guerre a commencé le 24
février daria accepté que son ami et sa
famille viennent vivre chez elles
anastasia est parti avec sa soeur marina
ses deux nièces maria et olga et son
bébé à lisa ainsi que leurs chiens et
leurs chats en véritable périple depuis
kiev 14h11 on connaissait pas les
acheteurs tokyo
sénat le 24 février
français réveillez à tous à cause d'une
explosion et on a tous compris que la
guerre a commencé
à din din din daeng installés qui
atteint jusqu'à mon avis elle m'a choqué
tony brown en une journée on en restait
à coeur parce qu'on espérait que c'était
pas vrai que c'était juste
pour nous faire peur non à sélectionner
ses paysages en belgique l'année
suivante ça explose et encore une fois
déjà tout près de chez nous et on a pris
une voiture on a on est parti avec les
parents dans l'ouest de l'ukraine les
deux jeunes femmes ont mis deux jours
pour sortir de la capitale est arrivé
dans un petit village à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de la frontière
avec la roumanie en cet arrêté dans une
petit village où les gens gentils nous a
accueillis et on a passé la nuit
on est reparti et juste ces jours là les
temps qu'on rentrait dans cette petite
village on a eu de la chance d partir
exténué enfin arrivés à la frontière de
la roumanie elles ont attendu des heures
pour faire 5 km on a tellement fatigués
on a tellement claquer la seule envie
c'est de s'arrêter quelque part et
dormir parce qu'on n'en peut plus à ces
moments là ils ont dit au revoir à leurs
parents à
frères fils marie les moments
extrêmement difficiles
le père de darial lui est en ce moment
au front at yani yves une ville détruite
par les bombardements russes je sais
comment faire
et il est il n'a plus d'électricité n'a
plus de gaz n'a plus de chauffage
sachant qu'il ya une graine elle fait
froid il neige il n'a pas d'eau potable
n'a pas de froide
on espère tout simplement elle est la
ville est entourée et peut même pas
sortir dès mon côté je fais de mon mieux
je fais tout ce que je peux pour aider
ceux qui en ont besoin moi j'organise
aussi le collecte de que ça a commencé
la guerre depuis depuis jeudi vendredi
j'ai déjà commencé à aller chercher
comment ce que je peux organiser de
l'être comment ce que je peux organiser
les collectes dans le magasin dans les
pharmacies malgré tout daria anastasia
et sa famille croit à la fin de cette
guerre pour se donner de l'espoir elle
joue l'hymne de l'ukraine
là
on
rappelle que votre association
perspective ukraine et l archère
justement de personnes de familles
pouvant accueillir des réfugiés ou au
sein de leur foyer ce que beaucoup de
familles se tiennent prêtes dans les
yvelines pour accueillir ces réfugiés
oui et c'est vraiment un élan de
solidarité exceptionnel que je vois
chaque jour se vend des emails de
famille qui seront
disponibles pour accueillir les familles
chrétiennes en france dans les yvelines
et c'est quelque chose de très touchant
est-ce qu'il ya encore des besoins si
vous avez un appel à passer sur sur
cette antenne pour de nouvelles familles
les femmes ils peuvent écrire
perspective craignait
naissance ont des besoins et en lien
avec l'ambassade d'ukraine en france
alors peut-être le site de l'association
qui va pouvoir s'afficher l'adresse mail
dont vous avez parlé ça y est elles
s'affichent pour prendre contact avec
vous est ce qu'il ya des conditions
préalables pour être famille d'accueil
pas du tout c'est l'élan de solidarité
d'abord qui quiconque et affectivement
c'est l'élan de solidarité qui compte
c'est trouver un toit pour les familles
qui n'ont pas et après être disponible
et
avoir à cette force pour les aider dans
des premiers un moment de 2 sur le
territoire fonction barrière de la
langue vous pouvez accompagner aussi
parce qu'on imagine que ça peut être
compliqué là on l'a vu le solidarité qui
s'est organisée avec le reportage juste
avant la question de la langue ne se
posait pas parce que la personne était
ukrainienne mais vous accompagner aider
malheureusement on n'a pas la
possibilité d'accompagner au niveau de
traduction mais les familles qui
accueillent les allées se débrouille il
se débrouille on trouve les solutions
c'est pas à l'abri d'avoir un toit et ça
sera en sécurité
je vous propose de rester avec nous a
évoqué le travail encore de votre
association avec grégory également une
représentante de la protection civile
nous rejoindre juste après ce reportage
que nous avons réalisés aux mureaux le
département des yvelines accueille
depuis dimanche dernier des ukrainiens
sur son campus il était en séjour en
france au début du conflit ils sont
aujourd'hui logés et nourris
[Musique]
jean
my songs and planes en guitare piano
oculaire un
lit d'hôpital et à
l'accueil des
jo in hand made in big youth
acteurs actrices iplay un dessinateur
michael leighton baines a laissé ses
atouts is
is not take you because it rock and
building
[Musique]
joe
biden ou
baby normalement baby baby cet écueil à
éviter muse à 8h10 inde linus omark gold
away si les
drogues peuvent être
avec ma femme lit in my time
underground ont tous
un des cinq mille photo ou une vidéo
wendy
de disques emi
[Musique]
à wenzhou
wang chao or going to school and
spend my iphone my
family l'école week end up est un canal
france
karting et tribaux et religieux
on distingue un des supporteurs find the
dope
industries d'haïti coeur me and
death
race
[Musique]
bon
un destin
[Musique]
semble au
beau
temps
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
vainqueurs mike se sont battus avec mon
mari
et moi sommes là on parle toujours une
piste pouvant jouer sur lavaur est
petit et droits l'homme niveau au
moins deux morts
entre mauvaise passe mal et hong michael
berrer 7 mac à nourrir ma famille
maintenant
alward musique alors maintenant je
consigne avait tué
[Musique]
et après après ce reportage nous
accueillons matile de franck ou bonsoir
j'en ai tâté les soixante dix huit vous
avez pris contact aussi avec une
ressortissante ukrainienne est toujours
dans son pays elle a également la
nationalité française elle habite
habituellement à versailles aujourd'hui
elle est alliée oui liana banquette fait
partie des ukrainiens qui ont décidé de
rester volontairement sur place pour
aider les milliers de réfugiés fuyant la
guerre donc cette versaillaise comme
vous le disiez elle a la double
nationalité elle est franco ukrainienne
est pour elle c'était une évidence de
rester sur place malgré la guerre
c'est logique pour moi parce qu'il a les
hommes qu'il combat pour nous que les
eaux de fond et je vois pas de zoom
fille elle ce qui si tout cela va faire
ça ou sauver sa vie pour se protéger ce
n'est pas évident non il faut qu'il a
quelqu'un qui va essayer et des faits la
connecte
privations je sais pas si après il
faudra qu'ils ont 122 blessés moi même
je suis
à la croix-rouge
unités versailles donc j'ai fait une
formation peut-être jeux pour tous si
utile
il y en a est situé à elles vivent la
ville la plus grosse située à l'ouest de
l'ukraine et donc c'est là où la
résistance s'organise les habitants
protège le patrimoine culturel en
mettant des bâches sur les statuts les
oeuvres d'art du musée national sont
descendu au sous-sol pour les protéger
le musée d'art contemporain et
transformés en centres humanitaires
depuis le début de la guerre les écoles
sont également fermés et les enfants
participent aussi à l'effort de guerre
dans la ville en préparant des repas
pour les soldats et en faisant des
camouflages pour les véhicules
militaires on peut au teich le statut
les fontaines on les protège avec lui en
équipe et aux textos ou cas où si l'abbr
bombardements ou si la fusillade vous
avez peut-être chez nous toute la ville
fait les camouflages les faits les
camouflages
pour les tanks pour les voitures pour
les blondes est
situé à 70 kilomètres de la frontière
polonaise lviv voit arriver des milliers
de réfugiés selon les annales c'est
environ 70000 personnes qui transitent
chaque jour par la ville comme un
pinceau 70 mille pesos qui passent pas
la bile parce que c'est quand même la
ville c'est le passage vers l'europe
pannoux beau parent qui en pologne en
randonnée en tchèque en slovénie on a
vous venez tous les pays là c'est nous
qui sont sur la route pas le cas rappaz
le bus ou les boîtiers et
chaque jour en moyenne soit 170 mille
personnes qui pensent mais sur place la
solidarité est toujours bien présente
d'après liane à chaque citoyen accueille
chez lui des réfugiés pour une ou deux
nuits et leanne à me confier également
que les files d'attentes pour aller
donner son sang même pour devenir
bénévole sont blindées et en ce qui la
concerne même si la ville se fait
attaquer elle restera bien sur place
pour aider son pays nous essaierons
d'avoir des liens encore avec l un pour
voir comment évolue la situation sur
place merci beaucoup mathilde pour ce
témoignage on poursuit grégory cette
édition spéciale sur tv 60,18 si vous
venez de nous rejoindre pour suivre le
conflit en ukraine la guerre en ukraine
depuis les yvelines face à ce conflit
les associations s'organisent pour
accompagner les réfugiés qui arrivent en
france et d aussi les populations à
rester sur place ou dans les pays
frontalier de l'ukraine signalons
l'action d'une association basée à
ecquevilly dans les yvelines c'est
l'association humanitaire les gerbes qui
envoie et dès qu'on voit régulièrement
dans l'est de l'europe depuis sa
création en 1988 un premier camion est
parti pour la pologne la semaine
dernière avec dix tonnes de matériel à
son banc le départ d'un deuxième semi
remorque est prévue ce jeudi la gerbe
espère pouvoir faire partir un camion
toutes les semaines je rappelle que nous
recevons en plateau elle les siae
darricau dmitrienko qui est habitants de
montigny-le-bretonneux
dante est de l'association perspectives
ukrainienne nous a rejoint également en
visioconférence virginie messmer bonsoir
vous êtes la secrétaire générale de la
protection civile des yvelines on va
voir comment réengager justement dans un
instant la protection civile dans ce
temps de guerre revenons à l'association
en perspective ukrainienne à montigny le
bretonneux la mobilisation est fait par
votre association en lien et en
collaboration avec l'amérique comment
s'est fait ce lien justement avec la
mairie de montigny le bretonneux notre
association dès le début de la guerre
elle se tenait prêt à activer toutes les
liens donc nous avons ou créer les
nouveaux liens avec toutes les personnes
qui peuvent aider le cren et par un
simple mail
au nom de
monsieur le maire de montigny le
bretonneux j'ai eu un retour et cette
action de collecte dedans a été
organisée
donc eu lieu le 4 mars ça a été
fructueux c'était beaucoup de celle
d'arrêter denim hautain et hypothèses et
d'autres
villes il peut avoir les dates des
prochaines collectes qui sont organisés
c'est déjà prévu oui la prochaine
collecte à montigny le bretonneux et est
prévue samedi 12 mars et elle aura lieu
à la mairie de montigny le bretonneux on
le rappelle les missions de votre
association prenne on peut le dire en
plus un peu plus de sens en ce moment
c'est promouvoir l'ukraine dans toute sa
diversité ses multiples aspirations
essayer de mettre en place aussi un
dialogue avec les pouvoirs publics
français communautaire et étrangers
ainsi que avec toutes les instances
internationales afin de les sensibiliser
aux problématiques du craignait neske en
plus des collectes il ya d'autres
actions en cours et ce que de prochaines
actions sont prévues par votre
association les actions sont multiples
nous sommes sûrs de plusieurs actions en
même temps on travaille en parallèle
mais actuellement il est important pour
nous deux
faire passer le message de que le crâne
a besoin d' aide de l'union européenne
et que si l'ukraine un pays qui a des
justes à 2000 km de france et elle tient
bon il tient face à cette guerre c'est
pas un conflit c'est pas un
une action militaire c'est en une guerre
qui était lancée par monsieur poutine à
l'ukraine on tient à
réveiller les esprits et posez la
question aux français et à tous les
niveaux tous les échelons pourquoi
l'union européenne elle montre sa
faiblesse pourquoi on peut pas répondre
de manière ferme et protéger tous ces
enfants qui meurent chaque jour toutes
ces femmes et hommes qui meurent chaque
jour tout c'est un ceinturon logistique
l'ukraine c'est une c'est un très beau
pays et on ne comprenons pas pourquoi
cette faiblesse est montré à un
dictateur à qui on peut pas
faire confiance qui a rompu tout laisser
contrat de prix 1 poule avec le
président macron et maintenant c'est
compliqué de
sortir de cette situation autrement que
par les
prises de
position ferme mobilisation très forte
de votre association une mobilisation on
l'accomplît à montigny le bretonneux
comme dans d'autres communes des
yvelines qui s'opèrent on le précise à
l'appel est de l'association des maires
de france en partenariat avec la
protection civile à un premier convoi or
celle de 13 véhicules de la protection
civile est arrivé lundi soir à l'ubs là
en pologne cette action humanitaire hors
des frontières de france est une
première pour l'association virginie
messmer est avec nous par
visioconférence je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire général de la protection
civile des yvelines est ce que beaucoup
de communes yvelinoise ont répondu
justement favorablement à cet appel
lancé par l'association des maires de
france en lien avec la protection civile
oui alors on est énormément sollicités
depuis plus d'une semaine nous avons
environ plus d'une cinquantaine de
communes qui ont déjà pris attache avec
nous donc nous notre rôle en fait c'est
juste de coordonner va-tout toute cette
logistique
donc nous répondons énormément aux mails
et aux appels téléphoniques des mères
qui nous contactent pour répond déjà
leurs diverses questions sur quel type
de don comme moi il faut les empaqueter
donc on est là pour leur répondre et
ensuite nous sommes là également pour
organiser l'enlèvement ou sein de ces
communes de tous les dons qu'ils auront
qui peuvent être apportées
il faut à ces collectes réalisées dans
les communes la protection civile vous
l'avez dit prend le relais comment
s'organise l'acheminement du matériel il
ya d'abord un premier acheminement qui
est fait sur l'une de vos bases
régionales c'est ça voilà c'est ça alors
il faut savoir qu'en france sur le plan
national on a quatorze base de
régionales
la nôtre est situé à saint-ouen
il y aurait certainement une autre base
qui s'ouvrirait vers rungis donc les
transports se font jusqu'à nos bases
régionales de là il ya déjà un premier
tri qui a encore effectué
ensuite d'autres routeurs viennent
récupérer tous les dons pour les emmener
en fait là cette fois ci sur notre base
logistique nationale qui se trouve à
strasbourg
donc là c'est toutes les bases
régional qui remonte à strasbourg et là
nous avons effectivement nos gros
convois donc nouveau camion poids lourd
qui viennent récupérer tous les dents
sur cette base nationale et qui les
emmène jusqu'à dublin en pologne donc
comme vous le disiez nous avons treize
camions qui sont partis déjà le week-end
dernier
dans ce convoi exceptionnel de 13 ko de
treize camions poids lourds de la
sécurité de la protection civile
excusez-moi a emmené à son bord une
équipe de quarante bénévoles
ça faisait à peu près un total de plus
de 300 palettes qui ont été emmenés en
pologne
composé de matériel médical et de
produits de premiers de première
nécessité et ça représente plus de 150
tonnes de dons qui sont déjà achetés ou
qui ont été acheminés déjà et qui sont
arrivés lundi soir à dublin en pologne
pour nous nous sommes une association
qui nous n'avons pas la possibilité
ensuite d'aller sur les terrains de
guerre donc là il y a un relais avec
donc bien sûr la balle hublin nous avons
nos équipes fédérales qui sont présentes
et qui travaille aussi en qui sont
organisées avec des associations
ukrainienne et ensuite la de nouveaux
convois partent soit par voie
ferroviaire soit par voie routière vers
kiev car div elise voilà
et donc c'est qu'on voit on le rappelle
alors il y en a un premier qui est parti
c'est orzel qui est qui est nommé ce
qu'on voit et on rappelle que c'est une
première dans l'histoire de la
protection civile fait qu'un convoi
humanitaire aille en dehors des
frontières françaises et commence à en
parler l'organisation sur place comment
sont affectés justement les dons
acheminés sur place
alors les dons acheminés sur place
c'est-à-dire au niveau des zones enfin
au niveau des mairies où vous voulez
parler de haut niveau des produits quels
sont les dons affectés par exemple aux
populations qui sont réfugiés en pologne
lesquels partent sur les terrains du du
conflit alors on a énormément de matière
donnée céphalées les premières
nécessités mais nous avons aussi du
matériel médical qui part vers kiev
écart div et karkhiv excusez moi pour
les hôpitaux également et donc il ya un
partenariat qui est en train aussi de se
mettre en place avec les hôpitaux je
sais qu'à poissy demain l'hôpital va
donner des dons et donc vont pouvoir
partir également on doit les récupérer
demain donc il ya cette chose a aussi
qui se met en place donc c'est le
partenariat avec les établissements
médicaux pour pouvoir acheminer
également du matériel médical
grégory nous allons reprendre le cours
de cette émission mais nous avons aussi
en connexion avec nous le président de
saint quentin en yvelines qui doit se
sauver ensuite puisque nous sommes en
direct si vous venez nous rejoindre sur
tv 78 sur nos différents réseaux sociaux
qui retransmettent cette émission jean
michel fourgous bonsoir
est ce que vous entendez président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
également maire d'elancourt est-ce que
vous m'entendez
on voit bien jean michel fourgous mais
on n'arrive pas à l'entendre est ce que
jean michel fourgous une dernière fois
vous nous entendez sinon on va essayer
de rétablir la connexion
très bien je vous laisse je laisse
reprendre la main on va régler ce petit
souci était de retrouver résidant de
saint quentin pour évoquer la la
mobilisation l'organisation aussi de
l'agglomération us qu'il ya des êtres
qui tentent de s'organiser et
l'agglomération de 50 ans comme d'autres
aussi et chercha à coordonner un petit
peu tout ça et hier se tenait une
réunion des d12 maire de saint quentin
en yvelines on espère qu'on pourra en
parler dans quelques instants on espère
pouvoir le retrouver dans un instant
virginie messmer et est toujours avec
nous un par visioconférence secrétaire
général de la protection civile des
yvelines on parlait de l'envoi d'un
premier combat rosales que d'autres
convois sont prévus dans les prochains
jours
oui tout à fait nous avons un convoi qui
va nous faut partir dimanche prochain
donc le 13 mars là il y aura 15 camions
poids lourds de la protection civile
donc non plus 13 n'ont pas ça quinze
camions poids lourds
qui vont représenter aussi plus de 150
tonnes de dons qui vont être acheminées
exactement de la même manière pour
parler justement du contenu de ces dons
disais tout à l'heure énormément de
matériel médical des produits de
première nécessité des produits
d'hygiène c'est surtout ça aujourd'hui
dont vous avez besoin qui est acheminée
sur place tout à fait donc on a toujours
besoin bien sûr de c2c de ses produits
mais actuellement nous faisons aussi un
appel aux dons qui est très important
alors c'est un appel aux dons pour
pouvoir acheter du matériel médical donc
vous pouvez aller sur le site de la
protection civile ces dons point
protection tirer civile point org vous
allez sur le site de la protection
civile vous avez les des moyens pour soi
faire un don par sms soit par le site
internet et les mêmes nous leur
fournissons également le rib le numéro
du rib pour pouvoir faire un versement
directement au sein de la fédération
nationale de la protection civile ce qui
va nous permettre d'acheter du matériel
médical et de pouvoir d emmenez là bas
directement pouvoir subvenir à tous ces
besoins médicaux avec le site qui
s'affiche actuellement au bas de l'écran
une dernière question virginie messmer
dans les yvelines au niveau des yvelines
combien de bénévoles sont mobilisés
actuellement alors dans les yvelines
je ne pourrais pas vous dire exactement
mais je sais qu'il n'ya plus de 500
bénévoles qui ce se qui se mobilisent en
fait qui partent des bases régionales
jusqu'à strasbourg nous avons plus de
500 bénévoles qui sont mobilisés rien
que pour se déplacer des zones
régionales et et pour aller jusqu'en
nationale est là en fait dans les
yvelines nous sommes vraiment en fait
trois bénévoles assurer toutes ces
gestion logistique donc c'est pour ça je
vous dis c'est un travail nous sommes
énormément sollicités car nous sommes
trois à gérer toute cette organisation
de collecte de dons et d'organisation
pour les transports merci virginie
messmer d'avoir été avec nous secrétaire
général de la protection civile des
yvelines merci également à notre autres
invités en plateau l'ittihad haricots
les cja darricau dimitrenko présidente
je le rappelle de l'association
perspectives ukrainienne est aussi
habitante de montigny le bretonneux je
précise juste que d'autres associations
sont bien sûr mobilis est mobilisé dans
cette urgence ukraine elle la croix
rouge française on va pouvoir voir
l'animation s'afficher qui lance un
appel aux dons financiers en soutien de
la croix-rouge ukrainienne du comité
international de la croix rouge et de
toutes les sociétés croix rouge sur le
terrain dans les pays limitrophes il ya
aussi le secours populaire des yvelines
qui a déjà mobilisé 5000 euros de son
fonds d'urgence pour les populations
touchées mais l'association a également
besoin de votre soutien financier pour
les actions déployées enfin le secours
catholique a également lancé un appel au
bureau à audon cette liste est non
exhaustive de nombreuses appel à la
générosité ont été lancées depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre le 24 février
des regards et nous avons toujours pas
réussi à reconnecter le lien avec le
pression de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines ça ne devrait pas
tarder en attendant nous accueillons
célia dates sont bienvenues sur le
plateau pour la rédaction de tv 60,18
vous avez contacté plusieurs routes rien
qui suivent qui résident en france et
dans les yvelines et qui suivent donc le
conflit à distance près de 2400
kilomètres séparent kiev 2 paris et des
yvelines mais l'éloignement géographique
n'évite pas la tristesse et la profonde
stupeur on a rencontré un natalia guaino
et marina baranova elles sont amers si
elles ont vécu à kiev maintenant à
natalia via voisins le bretonneux et sa
fille à paris la guerre en ukraine
c'était inimaginable pour elle j'arrive
toujours pas à y croire en fait bon les
tensions ça ça dure déjà depuis des
années mais c'est vrai que la guerre
comme ça avec des bombes qui tombent sur
des villes c'est c'est incroyable qu'ils
être sans fin je sais pas piètre d'un
mot qui a fait fort pour pour décrire ça
mais moi j'ai mon père qui l'a tant fait
qu'ils aient à kiel et du coup j'ai un
peu le les infos en temps réel qui sont
encore plus haut risque en fait que ce
qu'on entend ce qu'on voit à la télé on
habitait là bas il ya quelques années
donc en soi on aurait pu être là bas en
fait qui n'a pas déménagé on serait dans
les bonbons concrètement votre
témoignage d'une habitante a vu ciel
elle s'appelle véronique screwed si elle
est d'origine ukrainienne sont parrainés
à odessa elle en contact permanent avec
ses cousins qui sont toujours là bas
c'est une espèce de sidération et on se
dit c'est impossible parce que là il
s'était tellement heureux et commencer à
créer depuis un moment il ya par exemple
à odessa il ya un festival de jazz qui
ne co-organise ma cousine il ya et donc
c'est se penser que ça puisse comme ça
leur arrivait que lorsqu'elle tombe
dessus et qu'on se retrouve sans temps
après à la case départ de la révolution
russe où les gens se sont retrouvés sur
la route c'est quelque chose qui est qui
est inimaginable
on sent dans le témoignage de véronique
beaucoup d'incompréhension mais aussi
aux comme natalia et marina un sentiment
d'impuissance un finalement puisqu'elles
sont très loin elles soutiennent bien
sûr leur famille et leurs amis marina
est parti plusieurs fois manifesté par
exemple voici célia le président du club
de football est d'origine ukrainienne
comment vit-il le conflit depuis les
yvelines eh bien depuis le début de la
guerre il a pris contact avec ses amis
encore sur place il se sent bien sûr
concernés ils se mobilisent à st hier il
est en relation avec quatre joueurs je
disais toujours à l'ukraine c'est très
très drôle par rapport à mes origines
c'est sont exactement les mêmes couleurs
que la fois ci donc j'ai toujours way
toujours été fier sur le plan sportif on
en a pas beaucoup parlé il ya une page
hier dans l'équipe mais j'avais engagé
déjà les démarches avec deux équipes du
côté de kharkiv équipe de division 2 qui
est en stage qui a réussi à partir qui
est en stage en turquie mais jusqu'au 18
et ensuite les garçons ne savent pas eu
ou non visiblement il ya quatre joueurs
qui seraient capables de venir donc je
vais dans la journée ou demain finalisé
tous a essayé je vais moi même payé les
billets d'avion ces quatre footballeurs
devraient donc arriver prochainement
vous le voyez un wilfried grégory la
communauté ukrainienne évinoise
particulièrement touchés par ce conflit
suivez bien sûr de près cette guerre et
se mobilisent bien évidemment et le
stick merci beaucoup célia nous
retrouvons à présent le président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines jean michel fourgous est est ce
que vous nous entendez cette fois-ci
wilson un peu mieux et on vous entend en
plus donc tout va très bien est ce qu'il
est nous pour ce retard nous sommes donc
toujours en direct il est presque 20
heures si vous nous suivez sur tv 78 je
le disais tout à l'heure l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines se
mobilisent les douze maires de
l'agglomération se sont réunis les
maires de saint quentin en yvelines
quelles sont les décisions en tout cas
les pistes qui ont pu être lancées pour
coordonner et organiser la solidarité au
niveau intercommunal
est bien la première donc il y à 12 mais
qui sont
donc en harmonie avec leurs administrés
qui sont très demandeurs d'aidé de faire
des dons
de transmettre cela chacun des 12 mai
retransmet déjà sang de matériels
de dons de vivre d'être médical donc par
par le biais du département alors
ensuite un deuxième étage effectivement
dans le cadre de ce g12 et des douze
maires
on a évoqué
donc l'hypothèse
d'une intervention humanitaire plus
direct
on a déjà d'ailleurs une vingtaine
une dizaine et une vingtaine de cartes
peuvent se rendre disponible donc si on
confirme donc cette opération on a bien
entendu étudier j'ai un certain nombre
de places disponibles dans le cadre de
cette opération
donc on est en train de bien qualifier
l'ensemble du process de ce qu'il faut
bien sûr un point de rendez-vous
là-bas la frontière polonaise dont qu'on
a on est en relation avec à 102
personnes dont d'ailleurs des politiques
qui sont en déplacement là bas des gens
de l'ambassade de les ambassades de
france puisqu'ils et surtout
l'ambassadeur de france et l'ukraine et
et en pologne bien entendu qui qui qui
suis aussi un peu ce dossier
voilà on est dans la rue et communistes
à l'intérieur bien entendu ne serait ce
que pour les visas
de voir comment ça se passerait et puis
les comices avoue affaires étrangères
pour sur loeb le transfert les dons
directement
donc en ukraine ou en pleurer voilà ce
que ce que je peux vous dire donc tout
nom d
une réunion avec l'ensemble des
associations parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'associations qui souhaitent donner une
contribution est de participer à
l'organisation
donc c'est très prochainement on va
aussi bien bien sûr
travailler avec l'ensemble associant
qu'ils sont et craignent elles des selon
dr lacroix ou série d'associations qui
souhaite travailler avec nous donc on
prépare cette opération je peux vous
dire don qui sera confirmée selon bien
entendu l'actualité internationale de ce
qui se passe en ukraine
mais en tout cas on est on est en train
d'organiser une deuxième phase compte
tenu que la première continue tous les
jours il y à des dons et qui sont
transférées bien sûr directement conseil
départemental où est ce que je peux vous
dire de l'est situation que nous vivons
avec une forte mobilisation de nos
administrés les douze communes qui sont
très sensibilisés par ce drame bien sûr
qui tous les soirs et vue et les
visionner la télévision et qui qui est
vraiment
cette période où l'europe je pense que
dans ce moment difficile l'europe fier
en tout cas à une image aussi de
sérénité c'est un continent qui
visiblement est enviée on voit bien ce
se sera assuré qu'avec noam ukrainien
donc on sent aussi que c'est comme un
événement d'une certaine une grande
importance au niveau mondial et vais
certainement au niveau européen aussi de
demain peut-être qu'il faudra faire
encore évoluer les règles mais c'est
vrai que cbc d'une c'est très triste ce
qui est vu au nom de la démocratie et
puis je dois dire que la logique dé la
logique des armes je sais pas quel sera
son efficacité par rapport à la logique
économique un jeu coûte in a oublié et
qui vit dans ce temps en économie
mondialisée visiblement et que et qu
elle parle au monde libre là on est
qu'aujourd'hui doit comprendre le monde
libre ce qui ce qu'ils sont
effectivement créé un certain malaise
puis cette nostalgie de la grande russie
bon là on aime beaucoup nos amis russes
et je dirais que est ce que vous
craignez un impact sur l'économie sur
saint quentin en yvelines sur les
entreprises est-ce que ça aussi vous d'y
songer ce qu'on voit que la situation
est difficile donc il y a un sens
entreprises françaises je crois en
russie environ
on sait qu'il ya renault c'est que il y
insérant une entreprise de ce territoire
qui sont concernés leroy merlin
donc pour l'instant on rentre en
relation
avec eux alors ils les entreprises qui
qui sont toujours moins concerné 1 il y
en a certains qui devront effectivement
revenir complètement france d'autres qui
pourront rester partiellement donc on
est du
direction du développement économique de
58 étudie un petit peu la situation et
les accompagnements qu'on pourrait
éventuellement porter
donc à cette entreprise donc qui ce qui
qui qui ont des liens directement avec
cinquante ans de vie bien sûr que c'est
c'est observer parce qu'il ya derrière
bien sûr des emplois il ya le fait de
bien protéger nos entreprises de ces
crises parce que je veux dire que c'est
quand même un malheur
économique c'est un malheur aussi
sportive quand on voit que nos amis rue
nos sportifs russes sont mis hors jeu en
fait dans cette opération dont je dirais
qu'il faut vraiment que ce conflit cesse
le plus possible parce que les effets
pour la russie d'abord sont très graves
et et pour pour la france pour tout le
monde et le climat de sérénité qui
caractérise aujourd'hui l'europe depuis
depuis 45 voix l'on souhaite le garder
on souhaite que ça reste un modèle et je
à tous tous les politiques se
téléphonent beaucoup en ce moment moi je
fais du même d'anciens les petits qui
sont sur place là bas et on échange la
situation pour bien affiné en tout cas
si on fait une opération humanitaire
significative bien sûr de qu'elle soit
bien coordonnée et voilà quelle qu'elle
soit qu'elles correspondent bien en tout
cas puis vous si cons ont servi nice
bien sûr les ministères affaires
étrangères et de l'intérieur
pour que cette opération se met pour
l'instant je vous dis on est au niveau
de la qualification
on prépare également le vélodrome en cas
de nécessité
c'est un outil bien sûr très puissant de
solidarité pour organiser bien entendu
une telle opération est de 2,2
tout le monde se retrouver entre eux
dispatch les gens donc voilà on prévoit
l'ensemble des dispositifs associatif le
vélodrome les douze communes et
l'ensemble des relations bien sûr qu'on
a avec les missions à l'intérieur des
affaires étrangères et puis également
mis sur la préfecture voilà pour que
tout le monde et s'harmonisent bien si
cette opération donc donc intervenir
merci beaucoup jean michel fourgous
d'avoir été avec nous je vais aussi
précisé que comme vous êtes le maire
d'elancourt que normalement une
subvention aussi devrait être voté au
prochain conseil municipal de 10000
euros pour pour le créneau en marque de
solidarité qui effectivement et on sent
que nos administrés sont très
volontaires devant la souffrance du
peuple ukrainien merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous et donc l'agglomération de
saint quentin qui se mobiliser et des
actions vous l'avez entendu qu'ils sont
à venir et on va refermer cette édition
spéciale avec nicolas landry qui nous a
de nouveau rejoint en plateau rebond
soir nicolas monde évoque avec vous en
rendez vous qui demain sera au centre de
toute l'attention c'est un sommet
européen pour tenter de ramener
peut-être la paix en europe qui va se
tenir à versailles c'est donc jeudi et
vendredi et avant de détailler le
programme parlons déjà de l'impact que
ça va avoir sur la vie des versailles et
versaillaise est un rendez vous
exceptionnel dispositif exceptionnel
regarder cette carte de versailles plus
précisément du quartier du château
durant les deux prochains jours vous le
voyez différentes zones sont définies en
rouge c'est la bulle de sécurité du
sommet européen l'accès est strictement
interdite au public en orange la
circulation des véhicules est interdite
et les piétons pourront accéder à cette
zone avec un motif valable comme l'accès
aux commerces aux écoles ou un rendez
vous médical enfin la zone jaune sera
ponctuellement interrompue vous voyez
c'est sur le côté de la carte elle
concerne la venue de saint cloud et le
boulevard de la reine au total deux
mille policiers seront mobilisés au sein
de la zone rouge et autour du château et
sur ce dispositif comme je les dis
exceptionnel vous propose d'écouter
thomas la vielle il est directeur du
cabinet du préfet des yvelines
le dispositif de sécurité exceptionnel
qui est mis en place à l'occasion du
sommet des 10 et 11 mars se traduit par
un contrôle
de la zone du château et des abords du
château et également par un contrôle des
flux de personnes amenées à accéder au
sein du château évidemment mais aussi
aux abords du château le préfet a
souhaité mettre en place une cellule
d'information du public qui vise à
répondre dès aujourd'hui par mail et le
10 et le 11 par téléphone à toutes les
interrogations qui se poseront pour les
cas particuliers qui pourront se
présenter d'accès de personnes à
mobilité réduite de rendez vous médicaux
toutes les situations individuelles
qu'il faudra traiter pour faciliter la
vie des riverains dans une situation qui
reste exceptionnel et qui créera des
contraintes et comme vous avez pu le
voir affichées sur votre écran si vous
souhaitez des informations sur ce
dispositif vous pouvez contacter les
services de la préfecture aux maires qui
s'est affichée en bas de l'écran ou
numéros suivants 07 85 58 86 93 sommet
très bien mais un sommet pour quoi faire
alors un sommet européen au château de
versailles qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne
c'est prévu depuis longtemps mais la
thématique initial était un nouveau
modèle de croissance pour l'europe
finalement les 27 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des pays membres de l'union
européenne parleront des conséquences de
la guerre en ukraine avec la question de
l'autonomie stratégique de l'union
européenne de volley seront au coeur des
échanges l'énergie comme le gaz et le
pétrole vous avez dû le constater
wilfried et et grégory les prix de
l'essence ont augmenté de plus de 10
centimes en une semaine il sera aussi
question de la défense européenne un
sujet qui de longue date de longtemps
été discuté par les pays membres depuis
le début de la construction européenne
et après une première historique qui a
été l'achat d'équipements militaires
destinées à l'ukraine et ça c'était la
semaine dernière finalement les états
membres vont discuter de l'avenir de la
défense européenne ce sommet c'est
finalement la suite des sanctions prise
le 27 février dernier par les ministres
des affaires étrangères des 27 pays
membres et à ce propos on écoute les
détails de ses décisions avec à dinard
au vol lé porte parole de la
représentation française de la
commission européenne
la guerre est revenu tout le continent
européen
et l'union européenne s'est montrée à la
hauteur de 2 de l'histoire en adoptant
les fonctions les plus importantes de
son histoire c'est une sanction très
rapide qui ont été adoptées et très
lourde qui embarque déjà en de manière
très important de l'économie russe dans
l'union européenne c'est un sculpteur
d'accueil donc elle a accueilli cce
craignant qu'ils fuient et elle aura
offert protection
nous avons vu une accélération de
l'europe de la défense en six jours il
ya une plus de progrès en vente en
europe de la défense nous avons décidé
pour la première fois d'investir
dans des armes létales donc 500 millions
d'euros ont été investis pour livrer des
armes létales à l'armée craignant pour
leur permettre de se battre
aujourd'hui l'union européenne est
dépendante à 40% des importations de gaz
russe pour l'union européenne a présenté
hier un plan pour réduire
cette dépendance très très rapidement en
renforçant si à la production du biogaz
dans l'union européenne
on propose de doubler la production de
gaz dans l'union européenne et en
faisant un effort à sans précédent pour
renforcer l'efficacité énergétique donc
au mieux isoler le bâtiment
[Musique]
merci beaucoup nicolas pour ces
précisions rendez vous donc en tout cas
à demain 18h sur notre antenne en direct
et via nos lives sur facebook sur
twitter rendez vous toute la journée sur
les réseaux sociaux pour suivre ce
sommet ce sera durant deux jours et donc
avec l'édition spéciale avec vous et
grégory on va refermer cette édition
spéciale d'aujourd'hui consacré à
l'ukraine avec juste un dernier mot si
vous souhaitez faire un don si vous
souhaitez intervenir souhaitait aider et
souhaitait éviter que des mauvaises
intentions de puisse vous permet de vous
faire arnaquer aussi parce que ça on en
a pas parlé mais ça existe aussi
malheureusement il ya un seul site
service tirait public.fr et toutes les
indications sont données et tout sera
secure pour aider l'ukraine en plus de
toutes les adresses qu'on vous a donné
aujourd'hui merci wilfried et cette
édition spéciale est à revoir sur notre
site internet notre application mobile
bien sûr en replay excellente soirée sur
tv 78 et donc rendez vous demain jeudi à
18 heures en direct
[Musique]